[Music]
so when you think about the skills of
the future and what's really most
important I'd say learning agility is
probably one of the most important
skills that people can have and what
exactly is learning agility learning
agility is really the ability to learn
new things quickly and be aware of the
trends that are that are coming out in
whatever industry you're in in
particular so if you're a hiring manager
and you're wondering does this person
that I'm interviewing have learning
agility ask them you know what did you
learn last week what did you learn last
month what did you learn last year it
will give you a sense of what kind of a
learner that person is do they read a
lot of books do they spend a lot of
their own time learning about new trends
in in their industry if so they're going
to be the most valuable employees that
you can have in the future because
things are changing so quickly
year by year that it's hard to predict
what skills you'll need so people who
can actually pick up skills before you
even know which ones are most important
are gonna be the most valuable one of
the arguments that I make in the book is
is that typically corporate learning has
focused on on three or three primary
areas managers leaders and
high-potential employees yet that's
leaving 80% of your workforce out of
those learning programs that most
companies are focused on so what are the
80% of your employees supposed to be
doing if if the company's not focusing
on on you so I think that there's this
amazing trend that's happening where
people are realizing we need to skill
the whole workforce not just the 20%
that are in leader leader or manager
positions and so I think the trend is
more towards personalized learning
because everybody's at a different phase
of their learning regardless of what
position they're in and so for a
corporate learning organization to try
to fit one size to try to implement one
size fits all programs into the company
doesn't typically match what each
individual employee might need so with
personalized learning you can actually
assess what are the strengths and
weaknesses for any given role and where
are the skill gaps that you have either
to get better the job that you already
have or to prepare yourself for the jobs
of the future so I think for many years
we've been stuck in a model where we
think about hiring managers think about
you know where someone went to school
and what degree they got and those are
huge qualifications for whether or not
you hire somebody but one of the things
that we often ask is if I ask you tell
me about your education you'll tell me
where you went to school and where you
got your degree yet that might have been
10 or 15 years ago and does that really
tell you what you actually know and what
you can do so the the workforce of the
future I think is going to really focus
more on skills and what people can
actually do rather than where they went
to school because if you liken it to
asking somebody if I asked you tell me
about your health and you told me I ran
a marathon 10 years ago does that really
tell me what your health is like not
really so how do they talk the language
of skills and how do we get people to be
able to communicate what skills they
have and what skills they need and and
if hiring managers can start focusing
more on skills rather than degrees I
think that they'll be a lot more
effective ways to get people in the
workforce based on on that rather than
traditional credentials
[Music]